the diary ends with hope for the future
it does the the film ends with it with a
with a hope for the future but what so
many people don't realize is that the
aftermath of liberation was not a happy
one you're free go home didn't quite
resonate when there was no home and the
people who were there put you into that
camp so Leah can you talk a little bit
about what the experience was post-war
for you my experience during the war
during my hiding time I think after
there were after liberation no I just
going to say that during my hiding time
I was in a peaceful home and people were
kind there's good and there's bad Dutch
people as we all know I happened to
blend with the right people
when liberation came of course everybody
is very happy and the flags came out and
the orange was all over the street and
we could finally go out on the street
which I had not been allowed on the
street for over two years
and then when the elation waned I
thought ok I'll wait for my parents to
come and I had no clue I was 9 at the
time I had no clue what had happened
with anybody so I'm waiting and waiting
and then I thought jeez now what's going
to happen then after several months my
one surviving uncle discovered where I
was and discovered where my sister was
and that was the beginning of having had
five sets of parents before I was 10
years old so I then finally when I
landed with my uncle and aunt no
adoption was available because on the
outside chance that somebody might
return but in
meantime I went from my hiding place to
my sister's hiding parents which we were
liberated but I didn't want to be
separated from her any longer and then
we went to my uncle and aunt and then we
went to Denmark for nine months to
recuperate and then we went back to my
uncle and handin and I can only tell you
it was very difficult I'm sure we'll be
alive after day after dollar-cost I mean
you met mr. mr. Frank Otto Frank 14
years after liberation I'm sure he was
still in a state of loss from from his
family
I met him I'm sorry no all his life I'm
sure it must I um
very very shortly well I was in the
hospital and he came to visit someone
and indeed he was tall and very handsome
very German looking at Chile very kind
and he just said hello and I said who
are you and is it I'm Otto Frank and uh
okay dad was in 50 probably 52